there's word tonight that the son of a
saleh bin Laden is dead multiple news
outlets citing US officials as
confirming the death of hasma bin Laden
but they are not saying how it happened
or whether the US was involved husband
bin Laden was considered an eventual
successor to his father who obviously
mastermind the 9/11 terror attacks in
2001 and was killed by u.s. troops in
2011 Lucas Tomlinson has the breaking
news tonight from the Pentagon good
evening Lucas
good evening Bret the u.s. placed a 1
million dollar bounty on the head of
Hamza bin Laden in February details of
his reported death remain a mystery John
Roberts asked the president about it
earlier
Hamzah threatened revenge after Navy
SEALs killed his father
al-qaeda mastermind Osama bin Laden in
Pakistan in 2011 US intelligence
agencies viewed hamsa as an emerging
leader of al-qaeda who carried out the
worst terrorist attack on American soil
in September 11th killing 3,000 people
after the attacks Homs and other
al-qaeda members fled to Iran they were
detained but later let go over the years
hamza released audio and video messages
on the internet calling on supporters to
launch attacks against the US and allies
around the world Hamza is thought to be
30 years old the US government says he
married the daughter of a senior
al-qaeda leader who was indicted by a
federal grand jury for his role in the
1998 terrorist attacks against two US
embassies in Tanzania and Kenya a video
of Hamas's wedding was found in Osama
bin Laden's compound by the seals in the
Pakistan raid and released by the CIA
two years ago other documents seized
indicated bin Laden was grooming his son
to replace him as leader of al-qaeda
Navy SEALs killed another son Khalid
during the raid in addition to his
father
the CIA continues to hunt down the
current leader of al-qaeda Ayman
al-zawahiri an al Qaeda remains a
resilient terrorist group today in in
Afghanistan